et
[Musique]
les shadoks dans un louable souci
d'organiser la terre l'ont mise sens
dessus dessous
l'insecte gégène le propriétaire ses
vaches et les shadoks fuite vers la lune
[Musique]
et encore une fois ce fut la course à la
lune
elle fut sauvage elle fut décrit elle
fut terrible elle fut meurtrière
parce que ce jour là comme par hasard
des échelles à l'une ne marchait pas
elle fut meurtrière est
vraisemblablement la dernière car geiger
jura d'autant qu'il serait nuit
propriétaire la terre les shadoks me
remettrai plus jamais les pieds alors
des shadoks connurent le désespoir
fallait-il être venus de si loin avoir
mots durs et on de souffrance perd du
temps des leurs fall est il enfin après
tout cela être arrivé sur cette terre
tant espéré pour aussitôt la perdre être
condamné à vivre sur ce machin ridicule
on a appelé depuis la lune alors les
shadoks connurent la nostalgie ce jour
là ils regardèrent le ciel et ses
planètes n'ont pas comme nous maintenant
on espère on un jour y aller
mais en regrettant d'en être un jour
sorties
et au loin on y voyait cette vieille
planète shadoks qui se déforme et un peu
bien sûr mais qui n'était peut-être pas
si ridicule que ça élégie by pendant ce
temps là c'est imbécile a faisait des
faits les shadoks connurent la haine il
jurèrent d'anéantir gégène et de
l'exterminer alors commence à la guerre
la terrible guerre aux tiges et jane ou
qui allait durer des siècles et des
siècles mais qui allait gagner
[Musique]
et